workaholics talk about the show very
edgy aren't afraid to alienate
potentially you alienated the coast
guard recently which i think would be a
hard thing to do
how did you get the coast guard mad at
you guys I don't know but they're the
funniest group of people to be mad at
you
because they they contacted that
contacted us and were like hold
something about them right yes we did
something on workaholics where it wasn't
me it was onder's he he was we're at a
job fair in the show and he was making
fun of them because they were getting
more students to sign up for the college
job fair and then they're like oh it's a
CodeRed he's the COO brude would Azumi
and then they poured Mountain Dew Code
Red down his his butthole
and a dog licked it out sure analingus
yeah animal and analingus right so I
could see how that could cause some beef
and they came at us like I hope your
boat doesn't run out of gas a mile
offshore and we're like we don't own
boats
we're basic cable television yeah I
can't buy a lawnmower such an empty
threat I hope you're blue short of gas
yeah okay